i've not listened to this let's listen
to it together
and and see what it what it's
[Music]
david jimmy about philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired and listen to your
[ __ ] about unhinged trump supporters
and this and that
get yourself full of [ __ ] i i got my
hat's off to you
you can't you you you can't withstand it
david
you got my information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
flippy from indiana
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend hi can you hear
me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know uh
earning season is over and it's time for
you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes
uh
five and a quarter inches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the
land of the grace
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory i hear the sound of
winning winning winning
winning winning
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for a delayed white house
press briefing with the press secretary
gensaki originally scheduled for one
eastern
moved to two eastern and uh that means
that it should be anywhere it could be
as soon as 29 minutes could be four
hours the the way these things go but we
are going to be watching it and i am
expecting
endless dumps of questions about the
vaccine mandate and it's all tyrannical
and it's all terrible if you ask fox and
ben shapiro and steven crowder and alex
jones and all of these people
um
but is it really a mandate is it really
tyranny if you can just take a test once
a week i mean like is it is it even
really mandatory if you can say well
i'll just get a test once a week and
then
i don't have to get any vaccine at all
now there's actually an interesting
thread let me see if i can find it
there's this reporter who used to be
known as a left-wing reporter glenn
greenwald and i i don't really know how
i would assess his political views at
this point in time
he posted about let me see here
um where was this a retort about the
vaccine being free
let me see where it was
vaccination
july 27th
okay hold on
let me see if i just do a control f for
free
free
freedom of speech
maybe it was further back
free what's going on man now i can't
find it there was so oh hold on a second
you know what
i think it was in response to some oh
wait hold on what is hassan's
is it hassan [ __ ]
oh my god what is what is hassan's
twitter hassan responded and then it
went from there
is it hassan deep hiker
nope that's not it
man this is going nowhere does anybody
know can anybody help me hassan the sun
okay ah nope that's someone else too
this is nobody oh the hun i'm an idiot
not the sun there it is okay all right
so
let's see where it was he tweeted about
the vaccine being free in response to
glenn greenwald
where was it
this is there's going to be a big payoff
here guys don't worry we're going to get
to it
um
with replies ah here it is uh oh okay
here we go
so
um glenn greenwald made the point
yesterday
the unvaccinated in america are
overwhelmingly low income which means
any punitive measures against those
refusing vaccinations like loss of job
bar on entrance to public public space
or travel will disproportionately fall
on those who are most economically
vulnerable so
first of all this ignores that maybe
part of the reason why
the lower your income the less likely
you are to get vaccinated is that you're
in jobs where you're not actually
getting the paid time to go get the
vaccine so that's like what that's layer
one okay
but then glenn went on to say
the number of ignorant liberals
responding to the data by pointing out
the vaccine is free
and believing they're making a clever
point
will shock you if you look clearly
referring to hassan
then saying they still after all these
months don't understand why so many
people are vaccine hesitant
a huge number of liberals absolutely
believe non-liberals are stupid
primitive ignorant inferior and amoral
troglodytes and most kova discourse has
more to do with that bigotry than it
does with anything resembling science
but
hassan actually makes a good point here
their vaccine hesitant at least in part
because of contrarian grifters like you
constantly spreading these sort of takes
among others
that straight up deny that the vaccine
works perhaps you should ask tucker next
time you're on why so many people are
hesitant to take the vaccine i i feel
like i actually am unsure whether
greenwald really believes this stuff
um or whether he's just
kind of placating a particular
segment of his audience
people who pay for his sub stack and
whatnot i mean i just don't know
um but again you know is it really a
tyrannical mandate
if you can just say i'd rather take a
test instead and then i got a message
from someone saying well eventually
they're going to pass the cost of the
test on to us as the employees
okay but you can get a free vaccine and
get paid time off to go get it so so
like what i mean it's
just like we're going in circles here
you know it doesn't really make any
sense
but anyway i'm expecting a whole bunch
of nasty questions including from people
like steve ducey peter ducey peter ducey
um at this press briefing so we're
standing by for that i have no unban
requests for people asking about it no
unban requests the people we've been
banning lately really deserve it
um i want to say thank you to some
people that just signed up via twitch
and twitch prime and related twitch
elements
lukan nick lovin the font peg signed up
jen here gifted two
trisha norstar signed up in his number
six
mr browning is number seven today
hinhunk is number eight
rahenke is number nine
cosmos 84 is number 10 today
zog heed oh no zog heat was yesterday so
we're at 10 because much of today's
press briefing is vaccine related
today's coupon code on my website is
myhipa you will get an ungodly discount
for using that code at joinpakman.com
but you must be able to spell it
correctly you must be able to spell it
correctly let's get into some super
chats and then i have other things to
show you
desiree dewitt says via super chat hi
david huge fan you're my favorite
progressive commentator i got my husband
into you too
just married a couple of weeks ago
please shout out my husband kev
kev
with peace and love congratulations
and um
[Music]
i hope that you are now in wedded bliss
as the kids these days say
james montalbano
says simply sir
sir sure
trashqueen says thanks for doing a good
job david i love your show
thank you
pepe says can you help me get halo xbox
bundle is that hard to get like is it
are there are there video game consoles
and or games right now that are
difficult to get from the standpoint of
supply i wouldn't even know that like i
just assume you go on amazon you buy it
and in one day it's there
there are ps5 is hard to get wow
that's wild
that's interesting
okay um let's see gt09
says david sir sir i think you're doing
very well is there a way we can get
access to david pakman show songs from
the standpoint of listening yeah i keep
thinking about like making a spotify
album or something but then i'm like oh
man i don't know how to do it and it's
just it doesn't seem you can just upload
to spotify and
i'm kind of busy with stuff so
yeah but i i would i would be up for
doing that thanks also to horgis blorgis
and mads for super chats with no message
still love them
gorgeous now says hi david i was
wondering if you know of good resources
for getting into political science or
politics on an educational level in
general like to teach those subjects i
don't that i don't know
a mandy lynn says i find it interesting
that the same people who can't claim to
be pro-life are the ones opposing
getting the vaccine and wearing masks
makes you think doesn't it
let's do a couple of videos
oh hold on a second wait a second i'm
missing some stuff here
thanks to kaladin
for subscribing
with twitch prime that's all i'm missing
thank you
let's get to a couple of different
videos i have here is josh mandel
um
this is maybe the least charismatic
video i've ever seen also the audio like
you can barely hear him because of the
crickets
check this out but this is a guy who's
very angry about the tyrannical gestapo
announcement of joe biden yesterday hey
guys it's thursday night september 9th
i'm driving through western ohio we're
driving through a corn field near a town
called logansville ohio
my uh blood is boiling
enraged at what i've seen
in the white house today
trampling on our freedom
tramping on our liberty tramping on what
i took an oath to defend when i joined
them like dude what are you even talking
about could you imagine a less
charismatic person mandel josh mandel
marine corps
joe biden i'm not even gonna call him
president biden he's not joe biden is
creating a constitutional crisis
and as i was driving through this corn
field
i literally came across this sign this
trump sign he is my president
really because he's not the president
it's like
who is president has now become a
statement of opinion
it's my view that trump's president like
oh really well there's one president
and i am hoping and praying that the
supreme court justices that he appointed
to the u.s supreme court what are these
red lights is there have have the
authorities shown up because it's
illegal illegal levels of cringe we'll
do the right thing
and stand up for the constitution stand
up for our freedom stand up for our
liberty
is he referring to if you don't want to
get tested and work at a certain list of
companies
i'm sorry if you don't want to get
vaccinated and work at a certain list of
companies you need to get a test once a
week is that what he's referring to
and if they don't
i call on my fellow americans do not
comply do not comply with the tyranny
and when the gestapo show up
it's funny when you have the choice not
to comply with the tyranny it might not
really be tyranny right um this guy just
blew a 0.8 on the cringometer front door
you know what to do all right anyway
so that's that that's josh mandel he
says that the president is not the
president and that optional tyranny is
tyranny
um
yeah
he seems almost so low energy that he's
boring himself exactly i like that super
chat from matthew there
uh here's another video this is a larry
elder ad now on um
actually this might be a good time to
bring this up i want to cover the
california recall results on tuesday
they're looking better and better for
gavin newsom do people know at what
time eastern or california whatever just
we need to figure out what we're talking
about when will the results start coming
in like will there even be anything for
me to stream on tuesday night does
anybody know
because i would love to cover that if
possible
we'll get to the larry elder ad in a
moment here
nobody knows good
8 p.m
[Music]
8 p.m california that's late that's past
my bedtime
i don't know if i can stream that
not really any results on tuesday
after 7 p.m guys i said specifically
please include the time zone
8 pacific is when the results will come
in
8 15. that's going to be late that's
going to be i mean maybe i'll reorganize
my wednesday around that i don't know
we'll see
um
yeah all right well we'll take a look
we'll see anyway here is a um here's a
larry elder ad apparently targeting
generation z imagine if this guy was
governor public school is getting worse
his kids elite private school violent
crime is up but he has body guards cost
of living much higher he's rich coffee
shops closed for coving while he dined
at the most expensive restaurant wine
tab 12 grand he just raised the gas taxi
homeless everywhere he's in a mansion
it's clear now it's not about i mean
listen the governor gets a house it's
like saying there's homeless people in
the president's living in the white
house
yeah i mean that's where the president
lives that's yeah
where should the pres that's how it's
set up political parties it's about
incompetence it's about you gavin newsom
recall newsome bring us together
yeah
um
okay
so that's that's
that's an ad i guess trying to make a
point
um
it has the energy of a school project
yes exactly
exactly
um
yeah and by the way in all seriousness
if you live in california and you've not
sent your ballot fill out your ballot
and send it in please folks there's
nothing to wait for at this point let's
make really sure
that
larry elder does not become governor of
california it would be horrifying
all right a few other super chats
daniel says we'll know the results in
california depending on when the vote
dumps come in big massive dumps exactly
and that could be we don't know exactly
what time that's going to be
uh we are standing by for gen saki
everybody relax uh we you have not
missed it it was rescheduled from 1 east
to 2 east
so we are standing by for that
um people saying they are not getting
the my hipaa coupon code working
i i think it's working fine guys
you just have to type it in correctly
let's see if i can pull it up for you
oh is the website getting slammed with
traffic is that what's going on oh no
here it is okay so you pick your poison
monthly or yearly okay i think yearly is
the better deal but you know that's just
i like saving 18
so it's my
hipaa
right with two a's and then when you
click off
really powerfully drops okay that's a
big drop
big big big drop it works fine
and then from the standpoint of monthly
you can get the same thing
my hipaa
and uh
that's your 180. now if you spell it
with two p's
you will get an invalid coupon code okay
you have to spell it correctly you can't
type it like the word hippo you can't
type it like giraffe you can't type it
like snake it's got to be spelled with
two a's an absolute must okay and it'll
work i'm telling you it'll work
um
okay about 15 minutes here
let me play a couple of voicemails we're
still working through what are now
661 unread voicemails
let's take a listen to a couple of them
here
does anybody understand this car
period
question mark
hell no what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking
i mean seriously
this is a new caller we've never heard
from this caller before
yesterday to get a shot where the
[ __ ]
he's on the fringe
[ __ ] friends friends lunatic
bottom of the barrel
all right so that's a new caller
uh interesting
hey i think there's one thing
that uh people really don't talk enough
i can't i just can't do that i can't do
it with the with the rubbing you know
it's like you're rubbing a staticy piece
of cloth on the phone you don't need to
be microfibering the phone while we're
talking okay geez
hey you still there
this is a voicemail sir we're not it
we're not talking to each other
so
what kind of good time were you offering
speak up i can't hear you
what the hell
these are like extra extra weird
don't even know what's going on
hey david it's eric from mass um
just calling this i want to see how
honest you are um
call pfizer and
go on the line and
ask if
the
fda approved
the vaccine
yeah they did i mean what are you
talking about they did
and i think you're going to be surprised
uh
i already know the answer so i'll know
what would be surprising about that if
you're honest or not whether you put it
up or not i mean i don't care either way
but i'll just let you know
kind of a big deal kind of a big lie um
not the big lie get it you're saying if
i call pfizer they will admit to me
actually the vaccine was not really
approved is that
is that the argument that's being made i
don't know
hi david this is uh kathleen down here
in sanibel
i go as a brave wave that way sometimes
people think i'm a guy i love it
but uh that guy who called i think with
that creepy message i think it's an
insult it could be just a drunk guy
thinking that he's funny
but
i wouldn't mess around with it okay
i don't even know which guy she's
referring to you know because it's it's
like we have so many insane callers that
i actually don't know like which guy is
that a reference to
uh all right
their first public appearance together
ever and i have to say that my brain is
still in recovery mode from taking in so
many high level important ideas oh well
dave rubin calling in okay that's nice
great to hear from him
let's see what else we've got
um we have a five voicemail screed from
the drunk chicago guy
uh drum chicago right here um yeah no i
was sad man i didn't drink for like six
or seven days and i didn't even smoke
weed for the last two or three of them i
was gonna call you because
i wanted to hear how i saw it
i wanted to hear how i found when i'm
not drinking you know but
it's too late you know i got i found
some money and i'm
dude i never thought i mean the videos
pandemic i'm drinking heineken and all
right number two
here we go
no no
i'm not gonna keep calling i mean i got
[ __ ] to do i gotta clean the bathroom i
clean the kitchen you know when i move
out of the place i wanna i wanna make it
look like the way it was when i moved in
40 years ago yep gotta get that got
gotta get that security deposit back but
yeah yeah no i mean i forgot if i said
it or not i mean i i never really wanted
to box troy york i think he just tries
to ruffle some feathers you know all
right number four
no david i love what you do and like i
said i i just it just got weird you know
what i mean it was weird for me too it
was weird for me too and then here's
number five here i am you know my
magnifier just only line
like run ran out you know it just burns
out you know so here i am calling you
and it's just [ __ ] i'm so sorry yep
all right we're moving on thank you
appreciate that i do want to thank a few
people who just grabbed memberships on
my website i want to say that thank you
to rebecca robinson who just signed up
on my website dumps also thanks to
matthew shanahan using the coupon code
my hipaa as well as phil b they call
them dumps uh thanks also to aidan cruz
and sean kenner thanks to brook lynn
george hello
and sean clark one two three four five
six seven
seven plus eleven seven plus one is
eight nothing to carry and one that's 18
and uh this is a really risky coupon
code for a lot of people it could not
only it might not only violate hipaa it
violates osha
which is uh you know
that starts getting dicey but uh very
much appreciate everybody signing up
today
uh let's do a few more voicemails oh
sorry let me let's get back to a couple
others tim says sir could there be a
connection between ivermectin steroid
steroidal drug pushing and the
understanding that these drugs cause
potential aggression for september 18 no
no i don't think so that's a little too
conspiratorial
caleb says abbott has tweeted his
opinion a power grab by biden biden's
vaccine mandate is an assault on private
business
texas is already working to halt this
power grab
man uh
abbott is really
doing everything he can to support the
coronavirus
really really strongly supporting the
virus i'm sure the virus appreciates
that
all right a few other
voicemails coming in there are just so
so many
um
let's see who else we've got
i'm gonna skip another 10 voicemail
screed from drunk chicago guy just
because
we we might have had enough of that for
the time being let's see who else we've
got
testing one two three testing one two
three
testing one two three
okay you can now leave the real
voicemail now that we've established
that
the audio works
geez
what is the the voicemail lines have
been extra crazy
extra crazy lately
see what else we've got
you know david
it's so hard to do anything these days
i'm trying to
call in on the order line to get my
order in for the david pakman coffee
but i can't seem to get through to a
live person we haven't had coffee for
four years
um
yep
thank you
so um
i'm a long time listener of the show and
also a lot of
less
than youtubers
like your friends
kai sam and etc
so
i'm
actually on the left but i have a
problem with the vaccine you know so i
don't have a problem with the right
scene but i have a problem
with who is offering us directly okay
all right well there you go don't
okay um
another 12 from drunk chicago guy i'm
gonna skip these
we're skipping skipping skipping oh wow
this is actually like a 20
oh my god this is a 30
40
this is a 50 voicemail screed from drunk
chicago guy i feel almost guilty
skipping all of them
let's just pick a random one just to say
we've done it but i can't do i mean 50
voicemails in a row that is that is some
dedication
to
me amigo
davies
i'm willing to take out tucker carlson
in the fourth round
and i'm
i'm promising that i will take him out
in the fourth room
what
is he threatening oh the fourth round
of what the fourth round of what all
right let's skip over a few others this
is a 50 voicemail screed uh let's look
at one other
i mean
i mean i love you david i'll box whoever
you want me to
because
you're david pakman sir
you know who i
hmm
all right i mean i just i just can't do
all of it you know it's 50 voicemails
it's crazy oh here's one about rolling a
cigarette that might be interesting
i might go roll a cigarette
smoke some weed because
you okay all right
um another 10. this guy really i think
he spent the entire night this looks
like it's over a six-hour period in the
middle of the night i'm still just
clicking by just drunk chicago guy click
click click click click
um
here's the last one
i need to talk to you because
i was about to piss a piss off a lot of
people
[Music]
yeah you're you're
my best friend
oh i was gonna piss off some people
guys um i'm out okay on that note i'm
out and that's enough of uh that's
enough of that
i want to say a big thank you to dying
in chat who is uh resubscribed for six
months you were number 19 today
we actually our due to my vacation quite
frankly our twitch sub numbers have
gotten so low that it's actually
shameful we may have to stop streaming
on twitch
um we may not even be allowed to stay on
because the twitch prime numbers are so
low it is depressing i see people in the
chat saying it's depressing
oh people are saying the voicemails are
depressing sorry anyway yeah it could be
like a rip twitch type of situation
coming up pretty soon
let's listen to a few other uh
voicemails that came in
hi david um i was recently watching uh
i'm from dcm guy from dc
i was recently uh watching your uh
you're short about
these anti-vaxxers or kova deniers who
aren't afraid of covid because of
heaven and i just think that's
very funny because it's like do you
think not wearing a mask not wearing not
getting the vaccine and putting other
people at harm making that choice like
i don't know like put you in a better
position to go to heaven
like i would think the opposite that's a
good point if you're counting on heaven
and that's why you don't wear a mask
maybe god will be mad that you put other
people in danger that's fair
that's fair
let me say thank you to jamaiciro lerdon
and casey mack for the twitch prime
subscriptions caseymac
very worried says
don't leave twitch don't leave twitch
i do want to also thank people who have
gotten memberships on my website these
are just such great people
ambrosia
j has signed up with the code myhipa
gina cheret is a new member
beatrice stockler has signed up and
carol s as well as michael devore that's
four out of five of those folks
are are women
we have such a larger female audience on
the streams than on the recorded clips
it is really something interesting
uh we're going to be looking at the data
very strongly because it is really
something else all these shows like my
show sam cedars show the young turks etc
the youtube audience overall is about 70
to 75 male and it's it's just it's just
common across across these types of
online news and politics shows
um even having a female host or guest
host a co-host doesn't seem to change
the balance
but on the streams
there are so many female viewers and
also on my cameo i get a lot and my only
fans obviously but on my cameo in
particular i get a whole bunch of um
requests actually from very nice young
ladies i must say
tick tock that's interesting can how can
i find the breakdown what are the can i
see demographics on tiktok
let's see if i can find it somebody can
tell me how to look at it
um
let's see here
i guess it would be under
is it under creator tools maybe
where can we look at that
analytics okay
let's see what we've got
followers content let's look at
followers
i'm not actually seeing demographic info
on tick tock if anybody knows where to
find it let me see under followers
oh here it is whoa
we're only 59 male on tick tock 41
female i think that
tick tock then
is our
where we have the biggest female
audience that's interesting
41
let me see if i can check our instagram
uh where would that be so let's see
activity
i never look at the oh insights okay
insights audience
locations age gender
we are almost 50 50 on instagram
this is very interesting
46 of our instagram audience is women
this is off the charts
let's see if we update it for a longer
period of time
yeah 46 that's amazing that is not
common
most one of the big struggles with shows
like mine and i've talked to other hosts
about it is overwhelmingly male and this
impacts the
um
advertisers that are interested but the
fact that we're almost 50 50 male female
on instagram i think that that that's
actually huge that's actually huge
okay
let's continue
um
oh hold on a few super chats here
um
the irony of abbot and the my body my
choice power grab what a joke texas
texas has become a joke it's sad
lucian berrien says sir i live in
romania i hear anti-vaxx conspiracy
theories identical to republican ones
every day i don't think it's a
coincidence less than 40 people 40
percent of people here are vaccinated
yeah i don't think it is a coincidence
actually
sir do you suppose texas will put out a
ten thousand dollar bounty on vacs and
mask compliers as part of the pro covet
life movement it's so powerfully growing
there
no but morally they would have no
problem with that
oh thanks to rs nerd for the twitch
prime sub i appreciate that
deborah says david do we know yet who
will be speaking at the september 18
rally in dc no
uh september 18 rally dc let's see what
we can find out about it
what's the most recent
article
here's an article from cnn from just 18
hours ago let's see what we've got
law enforcement bracing for clashes
this doesn't really seem to say much
about the program
yeah i'm not really seeing anything
specific about the rally
leader of the rally matt brainard the
lead organizer said there would be no
violence from his group
this is a completely peaceful protest
well hold on is it a protest or a rally
500 people have indicated they plan to
attend
past events by this organization had a
lower audience
us house will be on recess that's good
at least one proud boy leader has
encouraged people to show up
but others have discouraged attendance
white lives matter we'll be doing global
demonstrations on that day
not the oh the speaker lineup has not
been released
three have declined three members of
congress have declined
oh all but three have declined the ones
that haven't yet declined are matt gates
green and cawthorn those would be uh the
usual suspects i would say yeah we're
going to keep an eye on that we're going
to be watching that extremely closely
that's for sure
thank you to kyle fabion for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
myhipa because we expect a heavy amount
of um
vaccine-related questions on today's
um
uh press briefing
we are promoting the coupon code myhipa
at joinpakman.com because that's the
refrain from many of these people but
that's my hipaa
give me a break guys
okay
important question why don't you use
your studio as a background for your
second location instead of the posh
apartment
well because i'm in the posh apartment i
don't have two of these backgrounds
maybe i'm misunderstanding the question
geez
denver says butterscotch sir we need you
to stream the 162.0 rally reschedule the
wedding yeah i have to go to a wedding
on september 18th but i think the rally
might be earlier than the wedding in
which case i should be able to uh cover
at least some of it
ryan asked do i think scotus will go
after gay marriage uh no i don't think
so and will scotus reform be needed to
keep her make further progress given
that they will ignore precedent that
second part is a maybe yeah that's a
different question
oh i should stream at the wedding that's
actually a good idea
that's actually a really good idea
um
let's see what else we've got
other voicemails
let's see what else is coming in
hey david this is uh josh uh from
virginia
i thought i was a member uh and it's
probably my stupidity oh this is like a
okay this is a membership question
so i'm not gonna do that right now
you gotta email in with membership
issues i mean the some of these
voicemails are weeks old it's very hard
to keep up with voicemails
let's see what else we've got
uh here we go
hey david so with the new vaccine
mandate from biden on 100 employees or
more
that you need to have be vaccinated or
get that negative test
one of the things i've been getting a
lot of mileage on to really upset
okay now the voicemail went blank
all right and we lost the rest of the
voicemail not clear what's going on
there
big david's eyes
so it's finally happened my auntie
back's dad is fine he's got coat but
he's in the hospital nice i've described
to you how he's a truck driver his
entire
uh and by the way i don't mean nice i
mean horrifying i mean it's just like
you know here we go again
distribution center shut down everyone's
got covered
his oxygen levels were below 85 at one
point he started to recover but um
uh
just beside myself right now
stamp his
his wife my stepmom and
his grand two granddaughters step
granddaughters are these raisins their
teens they're old enough to get
vaccinate none of them will get
vaccinated because well let's hope he
recovers i'm sorry to hear that oz and
yeah i mean it's you know the just get
the vaccine it's free you know
hi david it's joanne colleen from new
york city i love your show i'm so
impressed every time i listen to you
speak
and um i always want to ask you a
million questions but the most recent
one that i was thinking about was
why is your phone number 219 area code
we wanted david p in the number
and at the time we signed up
based on what was available on google
voice that was the only one where we
could do it that's all we have we that's
it there's no other uh that that's
really the entire story
[Music]
i think this is jimmy from philly
david yeah give me from philly what
what the [ __ ] david
like when the shrink asked me if i was
gay we really shoulda
like asked if you were gay not really i
mean i'm in a relationship with a woman
and jimmy says he hasn't been in a
relationship for decades so it seemed i
mean you should have said that to dr k
jimmy if you didn't like the question
now all that plaid you wear way too much
plaid
you let your girlfriend get pushed
around in spain at the hospital
when she took that cover test she
thought nothing of being treated
what
man that's that's weird
jimmy actually left a whole screed of
voicemails
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay another one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is he just playing clips when he calls
[Music]
really weird voicemails jimmy
okay
but does he even know he's calling or is
he butt dialing
i think you know they're gonna put the
squeeze on people
that's jimmy in the background what a
weird voicemail
people talking
they don't have to be telling the truth
about it yeah can they do it i think
that i think i think legally they can
it seems like jimmy is talking to
someone else about politics
but just calling my voicemail number
very weird
so anyway that's a he does seem to be
lashing out that's uh that's jimmy from
philly
i want to say thank you to a bunch of
people who just signed up inclu via
twitch including andrew dale just
resubscribed for 24 months there's only
a handful of people that are up to 24
months and andrew dale is one of them
thanks andrew
also bajibo has signed up via twitch
d pharrell
and kalinas have all signed up via
twitch putting us at 33.
also want to say thanks to lauren olson
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code my hipaa thank you
lauren yes today and today only unless
we decide to do it again the coupon code
myhippa saves you some insane amount off
of the price of a membership
um
have they delayed the press briefing
again is that what's going on is that
have they pushed it back now to three
o'clock
um
nbc now says we're another hour away
let's see if we can find that
press
briefing
september 10 3 p.m eastern let's see
it's gonna be pushed back till tomorrow
i know
um
whitehouse.gov
2 p.m press briefing they say
they're saying uh it's the website still
says 2 o'clock
so we'll see
very odd though if anybody gets
definitive confirmation one way or the
other let me know
thanks to multibeast as well as k shreds
for the twitch prime subs though that i
appreciate all right let's keep going a
little bit uh with the voicemails john
says sir why don't you use a picture of
your studio as a green screen background
for your second taping location
yeah maybe maybe something to look up
jessica says he leaves all these
voicemails to punk you in the hopes
you'll play them on a live stream don't
give them oxygen
jordan says i work seven days a week my
boss tells me if i miss work for any
reason i'll be fired i'm scared i'll be
too sick to work if i get it
well i i i would that uh something in
there doesn't sound totally legal
something some some but something there
is striking me as maybe
not kosher i guess i would say
um
all right let's listen to a few more
voicemails
hey david this is jeremy from knoxville
uh have you noticed how often tucker
carlson pauses to say this is true this
is how it is
you might think this is weird but it is
it's the truth again and again and again
it's almost hypnotic i wonder uh uh how
plays into his um convincing of
otherwise really really susceptible
people
yeah
i mean that's uh that's a technique
that's a tactic
um let's see what else we've got
um
we're actually doing pretty well as far
as voicemails go
margaret now we're gonna skip this one
here's another one
hey david this is mark
i am
curious as to
um what your thoughts are on the
recent uh
we'll call them new accusations on
dr fauci and nih regarding the
uh you know use of function or whatever
it is
uh i just find it interesting that these
articles keeps saying you know these are
research or they are
grants they don't state whether or not
they were already approved grants this
type of thing um i'm just i just want
your take on it thanks
okay yeah i'm just not sure about that
i'm gonna have to look into that
uh
yeah
hi david it's pronounced timbre when
somebody
is upset and their voice changes pitch
the
and and tone
the timbre i was waiting for this
voicemail i love that now i stumbled
across it
if somebody plays a string bass and then
they play a piccolo
they're playing two instruments that
have a different
timbre nope it's timber and i'm gonna
stick with that all right next is um
oh the pack dog guy is here
hey david b dog here
recently trump dog
offered to fight joe biden in a boxing
match
if the fight happened dog who do you
think would win and why i'll take my
answer off the air pack dog
oh man i don't know i mean
trump could be able to maybe throw his
weight around against joe biden in a
boxing match
but if it's normal boxing rules
i think joe biden actually has a pretty
good shot um
if it's ufc rules
i think maybe trump's weight
would become a factor
what do you guys think
like biden's yeah snuggles is right
biden's probably scrappy
biden just has to get trump down yeah
yeah yeah no that's true that's a that's
actually a really good point
uh okay speaking of which i do have a
couple of clips i want to look at we
looked at some clips from this trump
interview
but aaron rupar posted a few others and
i just want to look at them i don't know
what he grabbed but let's just take a
look say to some of the republicans
especially the rhinos because we have
some very stupid republicans also i say
don't yourself oh can i tell you you
guys heard did you guys hear that
laughing listen to that very stupid
republicans also i say
so i'm not super familiar with this
gutfeld show but i got an email or a
facebook message from a woman who who
says that i added the laugh track and
that i manipulated the video
it's like uh
are you really so stupid to think we
would add a laugh track and then make it
part of a discussion i don't know if
it's a laugh track or the or the people
that watch the interview with gutfeld in
the studio or whatever is going on but
we didn't add a laugh track that's just
such a dumb accusation let's look at a
couple others
all right so i have to ask you do you
miss twitter at all do you would you ha
do you tweet in your head like because
you're not on there anymore well you
know a lot of people think twitter was
bad for me i disagree i think it was
good for me yeah twitter's become a very
boring question why are people laughing
at that how is that even funny
as i
or anything but understand are saying
it's become very boring you made that
you made the site you know when i went
onto twitter like 12 years ago twitter
was a failed operation is there any show
that does a laugh track for a
presidential interview it's strange
and it became successful and a lot of
people said i had a lot to do with it
when they took me off i had
way over a hundred million people and
then if you add facebook and everything
else it's over 200 million people that's
a lot you go for okay i don't know i
mean it's weird
what a strange program people are sick
you know zuckerberg used to come you
know the lock boxes which i call the
unlock boxes because they unlock
so the unlock box is all over the place
but he used to come to the white house
to kiss my ass
and i'd say oh that's nice i have the
head
with his lovely wife and they come in
and have dinner with me in the white
house
and then you see what they do about me
and about republicans and it's just sort
of crazy but that's the way the world
works
what
what
what a strange thing and here's a bonus
clip of jason chaffetz
donald trump i think he created the
vaccine and
oh man it's got to be a comedy show i
mean i just don't even understand it
it's so strange
um
really weird really really weird
all right let's do
a couple other
voicemails i think we are going to be
going over uh
some of the people you don't like
hey mr passman um i saw your interview
the one that was broadcast as well as
the 2212
fuller interview with uh vincent
roccanello
on the september 2nd show
and while
everything roccanello said
is true
and accurate
there are things that he leaves out
because he was just winging it okay he
was just treating it like it was a
conversation
as opposed to you know at least having
some basic
outline of notes for points not to
forget
what
so
raccanello mentioned how the bot the
innate immune system tries to fight off
the virus
in the upper sinuses and the nasal zones
an explicitly mentioned interferon
all true okay interferon b and
interferon lambda definitively can shut
down stars kobe 2. but why does the
virus get a foothold
it's because the virus
codes for proteins that turns off
interferon production
okay that's why it gets the foothold
okay so we try to produce interferons
all right i guess this is a critique of
the interview with vincent racaniello
um
and this person continues to call back
so rather than getting a better mrna
vaccine from moderna or pfizer that more
specifically codes for
delta okay the delta variant
there actually is research going on
for a
nasal vaccine
that would immunize the nasal pharynx
and the upper airways okay
this guy's making a lot of assertions
here
so mr backman on a completely different
note okay
i don't know if you've ever heard of the
um aerialist
uh
uh aerialist uh they call him stunt
flyers is he saying areolas or uh
acrobats
uh acro flyers uh fatty wagstaff c-a-t-t
as in tango okay all right i gotta get
away from that uh james auburn says via
super chat
ad fontess media's updated interactive
media bias chart is out
your show ranks skews left
true
and respectably high in reliability oh
that's interesting let's i've never
heard of that ad fontes
media
bias
chart
let's check that out
um
let's see what's up with that i don't
think we've ever been in a a position to
enter into any of these
let's see go to the static media bias
chart let's check this out
september 2021 there's no way i'm on
here
let's see
oh my god now it's just
god what is all this stuff
okay
um
how can i can i zoom in on this somehow
skews left
tyt tyt's over here
i don't even see where am i on it i
don't even see it
cuomo jezebel
does anybody see where where i'm at here
go to the interactive chart
that's the static chart go to the
interactive chart oh okay uh
media bias chart interactive free
okay news source pacman
free speech what so we're independent
like we're on free speech tv i don't
know that we should really
okay
and can how can i see us against other
things audience size zero what the hell
we should be on here not as a free i
don't like this guys we're on here as a
free speech tv show free speech tv is
one of 200 outlets that we're on
we have no viewers
um
i would like to
does anybody know how we can put other
let's see reset
so we're around here i don't want to
remove
man
that's an attack on everybody currently
chatting on twitch
and youtube if my audience is zero
that means you all
are fake
that means you're all fake
um okay all right well that's
interesting so let's let me let's let's
do this
let me write where we are in terms of
placement so we are at
reliability 39
and bias minus 10 really minus 11. okay
so now let's clear this
so like for comparison tyt's bias
tyt is considered far more left and far
less reliable that's interesting
wow oh and they have no audience either
um
the date were considered more reliable
than the daily beast
but more to the center than the daily
beast that doesn't make sense
this is weird
we're considered more reliable than
rachel maddow but to rachel maddow's
right that's [ __ ] i mean this is way
off this is way off
well anyway
i guess it's interesting doesn't really
seem like they know a damn thing about
my show
but uh okay well that i mean it's
interesting to look at for sure
very very interesting to look at
while we wait can we watch the trump
arizona audio problem video sure i'm
always up for watching that
let's see if i can find it
um
those are some of my favorite videos
um
let's see i need to somehow catalog that
let's see here we go
oh i don't even know that this is the
right one but these are some of my
favorite videos
no that's a different problem that's a
different problem
um
hold on let me see if i can find the
actual ones
did trump hire antifa as the sound guy
yeah i'm struggling to find it i'm
struggling to find it
let me see if i can put trump audio
feedback
was that i think it was here right
around the 29th of july
are you back yeah i can't find it i'm
sorry guys it's just it's it's for some
reason it's so tough to find those
videos it's really weird
really really weird all right sorry we
got derailed here
let's go um
i know i really i want to find them too
i know that aaron rupar is the person
who
posted them
let's see
trump i think it was like derailed by
feedback
oh here it is oh wait no no no no here
it is
[Music]
all these people
let me recover my ears for once
yeah this is it this is it uh let's see
if we can find the full thread
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay good this is the video this is the
original video thread
um chanting lock her up trump derailed
by feedback
trump claims biden wants to ban weddings
here it is
[Music]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
now it's probably a rhino is operating
they're having a bad day today
they're having a bad day but we're
having a good day
thank you
it's all right
don't worry hey fellas don't worry about
it it's okay don't worry about it
the biden plan will crush you
will crush your family both of your
states all right and i think there was
one more issue
um
man these were the days huh yeah i guess
that is just those two
that one and um
this one other one
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
latinos for trump not reacting favorably
to the sound issues
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
you know i have a reputation for not
paying and it's a false reputation right
when somebody does a lousy job
like a microphone that's no good or like
teleprompters that fly with the wind
i say don't pay him
all right this was a funny rally in
general
there was one other thing here
oh yeah this this is a good clip too
trump like just makes up out of out of
thin air that like someone called and
said biden would be bad
i had a leader of a country call up he's
a very tough leader tough as hell
they're gonna figure it out maybe
although they wouldn't if it was right
if it was good they were not going to
report it
and he said i hope biden doesn't win
because he's always sleeping that was an
interesting second he's a killer says i
hope he doesn't win because he's always
sleeping you know i thought he was being
funny i said you happen to be right
about this is funnier because he lost i
think it's important to say uh hattie
won i think it would be very very
different
um okay yeah i know it's funny for trump
to be like
you know how i have a reputation for not
paying people that reputation is false
by the way do not pay these audio
engineers but it's a false reputation
it's not real okay all right let's
continue
um
let's see what else we've got
all right
bro
this is oz
and i see you
you put
jimmy from philly
that guy is diabolical
and you're you're giving him a full
blast platform and you're always
ignoring my calls and you shadow banned
me and i'm not oz i don't know how many
times i have to explain it to you we
haven't shadow banned you i don't even
know what that means i still don't know
how to shadow band someone it's it's
just we just can't do it hello david
pakman long time fan viewers uh this is
herbert
gilbert so this is troy yorke with a new
name herbert gilbert
um
i'm calling in response to your
program about joe rogan and uh
i'm a fan of both of you
oh sure long devoted listener but i
think in joe rogan's case
he
does not have covert he is full of
horseshit
and this is why he wants the horse drugs
i think he has a horse addiction
okay all right we're gonna get away from
that
uh and let me see what else we've got
all right let's get away from voicemails
in general for the time being i want to
say thanks to hi fam
who signed up with the coupon code
myhipa also thanks to jared tennant who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code myhipa putting us at 38.
thanks also to darth bane who has now
been subscribed 25 months i think that's
the record and the reason why i believe
that is is as follows we first streamed
on twitch in august of night of 2019
that's 25 months ago therefore
my sense is if we were not on twitch
more than 25 months ago
no one could possibly be a twitch
subscriber longer than 25 months can
someone gut check me on that
but my art is my arsenal has subscribed
darth bane is at 25 months
tina thiru has subscribed
ninja lags has subscribed so has dollar
batteries
catastrophic failure
and beef stews
that's five putting us at
43 for the day
thank you
uh all right
other super chats klaus says do you know
the good liars on instagram
tglnyc on instagram great trollers at
trump rallies let's check that out
tglnyc
instagram
the good liars
let's see what they've got
they have uh igtv stuff let's see
no
let's check out some of these videos
adam and like them get them or you want
to get them some of the spelling's even
right so you just came out and told us
there's a bunch of spelling errors in
there i don't know i didn't tell you
it's a bunch
this doesn't have a period there yeah
okay yeah there's no space after this
type guys if you keep doing that i'll
take the book back wanna just read the
first paragraph yeah political political
capital and content of god okay so
there's right here too see this is this
is all gone wrong here can you look at
them and like them maybe i'm missing
some context
if you could give a message to uh to
donald trump what would it be you said
you would be back and so that's why
we're here and if he's not back by the
end of this year i don't have any idea
what will happen to this country yeah i
i have to be honest i i totally agree
with you it seems like people are
believing crazier and crazier things
that don't make sense that don't have
any basis in reality
and
the country seems like it's it's in
really bad shape
it's in completely bad shape so we can
pray and um you know hope that the q
team has something up their sleeve i'll
be praying for you thank you
is there such a team like is there is
there actually a cute team
hey guys where are you guys coming in
from
uh avant lake
lake america first yeah all right
land of the freak home of the break
scotty
hey guys where are you guys coming in
from
uh all right pretty interesting
pretty interesting seems like they do a
nice job
jukebox request for rudy fart song not
right now not right now vhs says
voicemails have now become like kids
trying to go viral by being weird only
they are adults
my favorite right-wing audio glitch is
the news max clip that goes haywire when
they mention bernie sanders yeah it's
like there's an infinite loop
bernie
infinite
newsmax let's see if we can find that
one
let's see bernie newsmax
[Music]
not finding it it is tough to find these
sometimes on a whim
bernie newsmax glitch
no
all right too bad
yeah if only i had some kind of system
to uh
to better find those things
but alas we don't
okay all right let me pull up another i
had another video that i wanted to show
you guys
cnn did an interesting thing
uh what was the guy's name cnn
omar jimenez from cnn posted about it
let me see here
this is like really really something
else
oh no this is the wrong one
omar jimenez cnn
ah here we go okay
oh beautiful check this out this is this
is a a a journey
into anti-vaxx let's take a look at this
this spike is a little shocking it's
really raging here
everybody's scared everybody's coming
down with it it's almost like a plague
i have both shots of the vaccine and
people just acted like
oh by the way thanks to montyun for
gifting 20 subs on twitch thanks also to
jules's cools and azimur and the wallop
amber diane
uh thanks to all of you that's another
25 putting us at 68. all right let's
continue
it bothers me sometimes that people just
act like covet is a big joke i always
want to say well why don't you just come
right up here to the cemetery and i'll
show you my husband's grave and i can
show you it's no joke
over the five days we spent in carter
county missouri it felt like covid was
closing in around us
the positivity rate kept climbing and is
now 32
some people we wanted to interview told
us they'd just been exposed or were too
sick to talk this is a chicken picture
hold that in your hand we first came to
van buren in october 2020 when covid was
starting to surge in rural america
when we heard that one of the diners
we'd interviewed people in had closed
for kovit we wanted to come back and see
what had changed
by the end of this spring many thought
covid was over but in the past few weeks
it's raged through town
the vaccination rate is very low with
only 27 percent fully vaccinated 27.
[Music]
the overwhelming majority of our
patients that are admitted to the
hospital with clinically severe covid
are unvaccinated uh i didn't realize how
unvaccinated we were um i guess that's
my fault i didn't continue to push as
hard as i should have to get people
vaccinated because i thought everybody
was because the virus and the disease
was abating
but i was wrong
it came back like a brush fire
are you vaccinated no but i will be i
was pretty skeptical of it
until i've kind of watched all this
happen
jim's wife ruth fought cancer for 12
years but coveted killed her in eight
days wow he says the doctor told her not
to take the vaccine because of her chemo
when did your wife die
you lied to 20. i talked to her up till
sunday before she died and she said this
is bad she said you know i'll need a
shot
and i think she's right
last time we came here the debate was
over masks and it had gotten very
political we sit in the coffee shop and
watch people walk in the door we look at
a mask and we all look at each other and
we go democrat
later that fall there was a coveted
surge in the area
but the health center says this wave is
much worse in van buren after just two
days of school this august about 20 kids
tested positive
five days later almost a quarter of
students were under quarantine the
preschool had to close for two weeks
people in town were gossiping about who
had it and where they got it and they'd
all seen our last story
the last story you did well
i kind of thought it was all [ __ ]
myself tell me more tell me why that
ain't the way people are here i think
people here try to take care of each
other the little boy sitting coffee shop
don't know what to talk about when
they're talking about cody they need to
walk through the cold ward that stands
your mind but jim admits some people are
pretty set in their views good friend of
mine he hasn't had the shot
but everywhere he goes if he goes in any
place he wears a mask and he's probably
one of the best guys i know but now what
i'm not understanding is this guy said
he's now going to be going to get
vaccinated but why hasn't he
i don't change anything about him
he maybe you already
him would he talk to us yeah but you
probably wouldn't like white teeth
that's okay that's okay all right let me
give him a phone
hello hey i'm surrounded i need you to
come down here i'm
who are you serious by
well a bunch of women
okay i'll be right there all right they
they're gonna be right there
i don't know
oh yeah yeah come on
what
earth and buy you
can i sit on
why do you not want the vaccine i ain't
thinking that yet i ain't thinking
i don't like people trying to push a
shot on me or something else because i'm
this bold-headed spelling you've ever
seen
last fall dear god
how do you convince that guy right
well kobe put weyland in the hospital
for seven days i was on everything they
had
steroids full drip plasma from
people that had covered
drugs that they give my president trump
and they
finally burn it out at me
what's the difference though between the
fact they burned it out of me vaccine
and the drugs that you did take like
regeneron
well yeah
i would convalescent plasma it wouldn't
have mattered what it was but why why
would you trust regeneron and not the
vaccine
am i going to have a failure
i don't know
you know they well but one thing is
they shafted my president they would
have had the vaccine already had it
already had it but they wouldn't give it
to him because they knew damn good and
well he'd be re-elected they wouldn't
know so it's so weird because first he
says well i didn't get the i don't get
the vaccine because i don't want people
pushing anything on me
and then she makes a good point which is
you know the regeneron was also not
fda approved so like what
what why'd you take the regeneron and
not the vaccine and he's like well
because they the the vaccine could have
been fully released under trump but they
held it back to make trump look bad and
biden look good
so that's why he's not getting the
vaccine but he took regeneron i mean
it's crazy
so they had to swindle around and skin
around and keep it from him just as soon
as election was over here we got it you
shafted me out my president i ain't
taking your medicine
not from
i'll take what to give him but i'm not
taking yours trump got the vaccine
right i mean so if you'll take what
trump trump got vaccinated
he took the vaccine though
well he might have i don't know that i
think well do you do you think trump's
lying i give him the regime
they did give him that but he did take
the vaccine later on probably yeah i'm
not saying he didn't i don't know that
but that's what pissed me off and i
ain't taking it cause i'm that little
hitting
[Music]
there's no evidence for weyland's theory
but he wasn't alone in his skepticism
have you thought about getting the
vaccine
no way oh really how come
because i don't want to get sick and you
think the vaccine would make you more
sick
yeah probably it made my mom sick okay
what you mean when she got the
well she got the vaccine in february and
she got sick on monday with coke yep
maybe covered
um is she gonna get tested probably not
she's just staying home
and i'm bringing her groceries and
doing whatever i can away from her yeah
one of her friends tested positive and
she had been with him
so more than likely
i'm really behind right now because this
is like another country quite literally
i mean it's it's actually crazy what's
happening in this country i was down for
about a week and a half being sick and i
don't care i got it i told everybody hey
i had covered hey don't if you don't
want to get around me don't get around
me i do have it so did you have the
vaccine no why not
there's not enough research on it i'm
not totally against a shot i mean if i
have to take it and it's going to help
me in the future and not hurt me yeah i
might take it well we know that now you
know
it's always tough when we see this stuff
because it's like
in one sense we are talking about
people who have been the targets of
disinformation like these are victims in
some sense they've been they've been
targeted with disinformation and all
these things and we should see them as
victims and
at the same time like it i don't want to
be offensive but these people don't
strike me as super smart so how much of
it is just intelligence
i i i i don't know i don't know the
answer like it's not striking me that
these people
are particularly intelligent based on
the conversations that that they're
engaging in so at a certain point like
is this
is this a disinformation thing
is it an education thing is it both is
it that the education problem makes
people good targets for the
disinformation
um
i don't know i don't know
are you vaccinated i am not
and why not
i just uh i haven't gotten vaccinated
okay i had a
a lot of people around me had it i just
haven't never got vaccinated
around here we're pretty country folk
and it's kind of hard to
get people to
do something they don't understand
completely or they don't
don't feel the need to but are you in
that category
well i guess
i'll really get deep with you
i believe if the good lord wants me
right now it doesn't matter if i take a
vaccine
right so it's like do you wear seat
belts would you take antibiotics if you
had a sinus infection
would you get a cavity fixed you know
how how far does that apply
it's very very weird
i know i know a lot of people would say
well he also gave me common sense and he
all you ought to go get the shot but
yeah that's just uh you know that's just
the way i look is god more likely to
save people that have gone and gotten
the shot right i mean it's like you
could you could do this endlessly if you
want to do that
[Music]
i don't want to ever
give anybody an excuse
for doing something like not getting
vaccinated but the reasons
uh do hearken to someone who has you
know been told that they're a dumb
hillbilly all their life by the rest of
the country and that is not that's not
an excuse but it's part of the reason i
don't know that we're
oppressed or disenfranchised and i don't
know if we deserve to even feel that way
here but we are a flyover state
in a social situation where peer
pressure is
is so hard we've had a lot of trouble to
try to get people vaccinated to break
out of that peer group is very hard for
people has anyone wanted to get
vaccinated in secret
well um
yeah absolutely tell me what they say
when they're in my office and they say i
don't want to get vaccinated and this is
why and it's usually uh at the very best
a specious reason or a fallacious reason
we have set up things where we can sneak
one in your arm wherever you need to do
it because that's our goal can you
imagine guys
that's what that's what we've come to
now
it's hard but it's not impossible the
health center said more people in van
buren got the vaccine after two local
kids in their 20s were hospitalized with
kovid earlier this summer
last year we talked to brian who was
pretty cavalier about covid i guess if i
get it and it kills me then it's slow
walking inside singing for the family
what would you put on your tombstone
didn't wear a mask it took some
convincing but he agreed to talk to us
again and tell us what's happened since
and no one feels like they can trust our
government it's not my fault no one's no
one's wearing their mouths but it's not
my seems this is the real ozark not the
one uh
not the one with laura linney and uh
jason um
oh my god uh jason
what's the guy's name
somebody
jason bateman exactly yeah less
glamorous someone's taking the vaccine
it's the government's fault
if you get the back seat
please right
[Music]
whether you think you're a big tough guy
or whatever
anything it doesn't matter
if you get it it can kill you
so did he get vaccinated i want my
wife to have to wonder
when they
put you in a medical induced coma
and have your teeth stick a tube down
your throat is he going to come back out
of that
that's why i got a vaccine ah
ellie he got the vaccine okay
i mean
very very interesting video
but extraordinarily depressing
extraordinarily depressing wow
that is uh that is something huh
um
thanks to hydrogen
for subscribing via twitch prime you are
number 69 today
also want to say thank you to jake
conklin who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code my myhipa
number 70 today very much appreciate
that if you're just joining us we're
standing by for jensaki now almost two
hours late if you can believe it almost
two hours late expecting endless nasty
questions about the vaccine mandate
announced yesterday a mandate which you
can circumvent just by getting tested if
you prefer
um
because it is going to be a heavy
vaccine press conference
we have the coupon code myhipa available
on my website you can use that code to
save and save big
as you can see here i've typed in the
coupon code
and look at these outrageous prices
these are crazy crazy prices and we've
been thanking everybody who signs up
on the website let me get caught up on
super chats while we were watching that
a few of these uh flew by and i didn't
see them vash says how to deal with that
guy is ask him what he wants on his
tombstone if he gets the virus hopefully
he doesn't get it be safe everyone yes
jimmy from philly says circle back david
yeah yeah i know jen saki she says
circle back i got it
mart says i was glad to live in quebec
canada where school districts wear free
of anti-vaxx message but today today i
saw that some school were full of
anti-vaxx message on their
walls
that doesn't sound good
justin andrew watson says david sir i
resubbed and didn't hear my name i don't
know where you did it
but thank you justin i appreciate that
very much appreciate that
um
okay oh people seemed interested in the
anti-vaccine interview let me pull one
other one out of my hat which i had here
hold on
you might find i mean they're depressing
but they are fascinating
uh let me see where was this one
see how i can find it anti-vaxx
interview
nope
is it anti-vaccine interview
yeah i'm having trouble finding it
hold on anti-vaccine interview with a
space maybe
yeah i'm not finding it
i apologize i had a bunch of stuff cued
let me take one more look at it
yeah i'm not able to find it
okay
i'll just pull up my other list of stuff
that i had for you guys
um i did the apple store meltdown
okay here's one other mask meltdown
meltdown and again one of the things
we've been asking is like are these just
merely mentally ill people pressure
this is christ man
what's the matter this is america
not 1920 russia
hey
[Music]
everybody's a constitutional expert all
of a sudden
[Music]
you
nazi okay yeah so there's that guy
here not all of these are new [ __ ] you
no it's not enough park your car
okay
i don't listen to you either listen you
short [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay
chris oh man she told me my star [ __ ]
piece
all right so very very much against
masking
uh let's see a couple others here girl
here wants me to come out of the
elevator so she can come out of the
elevator
because it's a small space we're
supposed to maintain social distancing i
don't understand why you can't just
politely step out
of the elevator but i asked you nicely
well you have been wearing your mouth
you didn't like me nicely you said get
the [ __ ] out the elevator this seems
like a different problem here after you
reach no no no no no no no
what on earth
oh my god hold on hold on my girl
you wanna stand in the elevator with me
and catch it like you're not making
sense on you you might as well get up at
your floor i'm trying to get out there i
can't come close to you do you not
understand that i haven't extremely
confident so tension's running very very
high um going through just a couple of
these here's a woman who wanted to get
her
she wanted to go to the dentist and
didn't want to wear a mask it's like
come on guys we know what medical office
is it's masking we're doing masking
i don't wear a mask getting my teeth
cleaned but it's about the safety from
art
i'll cover my mouth can i go be seated
now no because you're not you're not
filling out the forms or letting us take
your temperature it's about protecting
you can't take my temperature that's
against the law all right well i can't
you're
[Music]
that's true she has a right to sue
whoever she wants whether the lawsuit is
bs
she's that she's right she's right she
has a right to make any lawsuits she
wants to get a lawyer to file
and this entire company smile she'll
lose yeah of course
i do have that right and i talked to my
attorney before i came here too imagine
hey sir attorney counselor
do i have the right to sue my dentist if
i don't like it yeah you have the right
to sue them sure i don't think it means
what you think it means though so does
he want that to happen i've waited long
enough for my teeth to be cleaned okay
let's get this done
okay they're telling me i can't see you
who's there
the owner of the practice i want to hear
him get him on the phone
he has to send me in written writing
written writing not spoken writing
without a mask either i can do what i
want i'm free it's not a lawyer
it's not a lawyer
no all right so anyway there's that and
then here's one more this is a recent
one which i did not yet have a chance to
look at
this is a guy
having some kind of a meltdown on a
plane it was really weird
he's like eating the mask
is this just is this a political
statement or is this a psychotic break
[Music]
now i have to say this person's also not
really wearing the mask correctly is
this a pilot or a flight attendant i
don't know what this is but this
individual is also wearing the mask
weirdly
[Music]
set
yes they think
of america
they
think
and it is
um
america
man what a humiliation
you really have to be extra careful now
on planes because if you lose it you're
gonna it's gonna get filmed you know
um i think i posted one of these just
keeping an eye on jen saki should be any
moment now
uh
i think i posted one of these
not this one no we we did coughing
coughing woman
uh oh i guess i didn't okay anyway yeah
the it's it's
the it's like
this is obviously mental illness serious
mental illness of some kind and or
alcoholism but at the same time it's
become so political that where
it's a combination of
if you have certain
conditions
and certain political views your public
meltdown will be related to something
like this whereas people on the left
also have psychotic breaks and different
things they're not going to be over not
wearing a mask it's going to be about
you know who knows what something else i
guess is the point
um very oppressive mask wearing what's
happening there
thank you to
gemma galaxy or galaxy who just signed
up on my website with the coupon code
myhippa also thank you to patrick
weatherly welcoming you as a new member
as well number 71 and 72. thank you also
to zebo jojo number 73 over on twitch
today very much appreciate that
they all behave like they are heroes or
righteous says josh yeah
so many sorry ross
so many worried about long-term effects
of the vaccine but why not the virus
long-term lung damage clotting issues
sensory issues illogical i agree with
you i agree with you
jeff says maybe a required class in high
school should be statistics media
literacy analyzing science literature
and studies yeah i actually had a great
conversation yesterday on the show with
henry giroux
and we talked about that very strongly
very very strongly
um
angie says hell yeah gen saki to me
and now two hours late two hours late we
are finally going to get
to the press briefing shouldn't even be
legal quite frankly i think this is
peter ducey ready to ask some nasty
questions
um this is a perfect time by the way to
re-up that twitch prime subscription if
you have amazon prime you can subscribe
for free
you take five bucks out of jeff bezos's
pocket hard to imagine a better deal
than that
um
[Music]
this is a good question is it important
to take breaks from the news yes
from now until monday i'm on a i'm going
to be on a break from the news i think
it is very important very important i've
spoken about that before
let's see here
what else do we have
will the craziness never stop i'm so
exhausted
yes
very much so
yeah mental health breaks of course yeah
over the weekend i'll read history and
philosophy and fiction but just not not
pay attention to the news oh
i think i can maybe squeeze in
another voicemail or two
yeah psycho once before my daughter got
the vaccine her second dose
uh was in may she was fine on the day
she got it and then
in the evening whoa actually this i
actually i'm reading ahead and i don't i
i i can't actually air what this
person's about to say i'm going to have
to skip that
hi everyone all right here's gensock
thank you for your patience i know
you're all thrilled to be sitting here
at three o'clock on a friday afternoon
but here we are together uh okay so i
have two items for all of you at the top
uh today the white house competition
council which includes eight cabinet
secretaries and the chairs of seven
independent agencies held its inaugural
meeting here in the roosevelt room of
the white house the council's first
meeting focused on the actions agencies
have already taken to promote
competition and help lower costs for
american families in just the two months
since the president issued the
competition executive order the members
of the competition council have met
every deadline in the executive order so
far and delivered even more than what
was required ahead of schedule the
agency's actions cover a broad range of
industries and are aimed at reducing the
prices people pay when they shop at the
grocery store when they travel to visit
their loved ones when they're choosing
an internet plan and when they purchase
the prescription drugs they need during
the meeting several agencies including
hhs dot usda doj and ftc and the ftc
briefed the other council members on the
important work they've done this
includes a major effort by the
department of transportation to get
refunds for thousands of travelers whose
flights were cancelled due to covet 19.
dot published a new report highlighting
how it is helping secure refunds for
thousands of those passengers including
by investigating the refund practices of
18 airlines filing a formal complaint
against air canada for refund delays and
getting nine airlines to change their
refund policies so that passengers can
get refunded more quickly this is just
the beginning obviously more work ahead
a quick preview of the week ahead you
know a lot of this already but tomorrow
the present first lady will honor and
memorialize the lives lost with travel
to all three sites of the 9 11 attacks
visiting new york city shanksville
pennsylvania and the pentagon on monday
the president will travel to boise idaho
where he will visit the national
interagency fire center he will also
head to sacramento california to survey
wildfire damage that has affected the
region then the president will head to
long beach california to participate in
an event with governor gavin newsom on
tuesday he will travel to denver
colorado to participate in a build back
better infrastructure event uh we will
have more details i expect over the
coming days more to come in the schedule
for the week ahead uh with that alex go
ahead here we
go you could comment on some new
reporting from my colleague that uh
health concerns have halted us bound
flights of afghanistan evacuees from
two uh key countries
what was behind that is it covet related
do you know how many afghan refugees are
affected sure
let me give you the information we have
at this point uh
operation or i have i should say at this
point operation allies uh welcome
flights into the united states have been
temporarily paused at the request of the
cdc
and out of an abundance of caution
because of four diagnosed cases of
measles whoa
fans who recently arrived in the united
states these individuals are being
quarantined in accordance with public
health guidelines and the cdc has begun
full contact tracing all arriving
afghans are currently required to be
vaccinated for measles as a condition of
entry into the united states and
critical immunizations including
mnr are being administered for afghans
at military bases in the united states
wow and we are also mmr sorry we are
also exploring measures to vaccinate
people while they are still overseas so
that's something we're looking into but
it was again a step recommended by the
cdc out of an abundance of caution given
for measles cases and i wanted to ask
about a change in tone from the
administration when it comes to blaming
the unvaccinated uh-oh here we go
governor ivy said it's time to start
blaming unvaccinated folks and you said
quote you didn't you didn't think it was
quote our role to place blame and it was
quote not the role of the federal
government to blame but that's pretty
much what president biden did yesterday
so what has shifted you know in these
months that you've decided to take a
more aggressive tone well i would i
don't think it will surprise you i
wouldn't characterize his speech in
exactly those words or that terminology
uh what you heard the president convey
yesterday is the next steps that he is
taking using every lever of government
to
reduce uh his sicknesses to reduce
hospitalizations to protect more people
and save more lives i will say that he
was channeli channeling the frustration
that millions of people across this
country are feeling who are vaccinated
true and many governors and elected
officials have uh also uh shared uh
their frustration over and as is uh the
case i mean it is also true that uh
there has also been a growing
frustration among people so if you look
at the trends over the last couple of
months
you know we didn't anticipate i will say
that when there was a vaccine approved
by
under a republican president
that the republican president took that
there would be such hesitation
opposition uh vehement opposition in
some cases from so many people of his
own party in this country we didn't
anticipate that it's also true that uh
there are many people in this country
who weren't vaccinated who said i'm just
waiting for the fda to approve the
vaccine that happened several weeks ago
there's still 80 million people who were
unvaccinated and we've also seen during
this time the delta variant a
transmissible variant pose greater risk
put more people in hospitals including
kids so that is why people across the
country are frustrated who are
vaccinated and certainly the president
was channeling that yesterday one more
quick one on osha can you talk about
enforcement of the vaccine mandate for
businesses we've already seen a lot of
evidence they get three questions each
there was an id report that suggested
even though there's been more osha
complaints that there's been fewer
investigations so will the
administration be providing more
resources to osha and help them to
implement this mandate how will it work
that's a great question alex obviously
the president just announced the steps
yesterday there'll be there'll be a
rule-making process that's going to take
a little bit of time uh and certainly
whatever resources they need i'm sure
the president will want them to have
good
just a follow-up on on the enforcement
of that realistically i mean how long
could it take some experts say it could
take months and the effects of this new
rule especially for companies may not be
felt in time for the delta wave do you
have an estimation on how long it could
take
i don't have an estimation for you today
but there's clearly an urgency here and
we want to ensure that rulemaking
proceeds uh rapidly as quickly as
possible i'll also note though that
there are a number of companies that
have already put requirements in place
united airlines tyson foods southwest
houston methodist the huge hospital
system was one of the biggest ones that
did this early they had a varying number
of days for implementation but
certainly we're going to put every
resource in the federal government to
get this going rapidly we've also seen
announcements southwest airlines
announced today it was taking the next
steps toward full compliance and
business roundtable issued a statement
welcoming the president's announcement
do it for passengers up to a number of
private sector companies our expectation
and hope is they will take these steps
on their own and then we will continue
to implement for those who are not
complying
another question on the republicans that
have come out
obviously criticizing the new
requirements 19 republican governors
have said that they plan to fight this
has the white house been in contact with
any of those governors who have
criticized this since the president made
this announcement yesterday
i don't have any engagements or calls to
read out for you we are in touch with a
range of governors democratic and
republican every week if not more
frequently about a range of topics
including our efforts to address
the pandemic we're also in touch with
health officials up and down the the the
lines in these uh in these states who
are often implementing these plans and
policies one last question for you just
an appeals court just ruled in favor of
governor ron desantis in his
administration saying the state could
not enforce a ban on strict mass
mandates just a response to that are you
concerned that this is going to put more
children at risk in that state well one
of the steps the president announced
yesterday is that we have the funding
the resources and the intention of
having the back of school leaders in
school districts superintendents and
others who do the right thing by
students and that includes putting in
place mass requirements and other
requirements that will keep them safe
good
jen with the 911 commemorations can you
tell me
what you are doing to sort of
go back and
address the huge massive wave of hate
crimes that we saw against arab
americans muslim americans and those who
were taken to be either arab or muslim
from 20 years ago what is the white
house's plan to address that component
of the history of the aftermath of the
attacks
well first i would say that um guys i'm
sorry it's a bit of a weird question for
uh equity that we are speaking out that
we are taking actions against hate
crimes uh verbal abuse of any kind
against any group is certainly central
to what we in this administration i'm
not devaluing protecting people who are
targeted for their identity
what are you going to do about the fact
that 20 years ago it's sort of like it's
kind of like what happened with asian
people because of the uh
pandemic now happened with
you know people perceived to be muslim
20 years ago but i don't know
is that why is now what i was talking
about this the other day with some of us
and conveying that uh you know he
remembers that day being on the train on
the way to washington the first thing he
wanted to do uh was to go to the floor
of the capitol and conveyed to the
american people that this is a time to
come together and so that will certainly
be central to his message it's not just
words i'm not suggesting that but that
is certainly what you will hear him say
in this video and what we'll continue to
convey
i would say though that there will
continue to be efforts and actions by
the department of justice by agencies
across government to
fight hate crimes to speak out against
them and to take any actions in our
power to do that can i just follow up on
that just in terms of the unity question
so i tried to ask the president today at
the
at the event at the school whether he's
concerned that his actions you know
we've seen the backlash from republicans
and
other others
in terms of the vaccination mandates
is he concerned that you know what's
happening now is actually driving the
country further apart
um both in terms of the vaccinations
uh-oh
should we switch let's maybe go over
here
there's a lot of controversy and
divisiveness also about
afghanistan and how that was handled i
mean
you know are you are you worried that at
this point the country's getting further
apart and is biden doing too much and
some people don't like it
the president believes that the reason
he made the took the steps he did
yesterday is because he believes that
beyond politics that the role of the
president of the united states is to
protect people and save their lives uh
it wasn't that we didn't anticipate
there would be strong reactions and
there were
but ultimately 75 percent of adults who
are eligible in this country are
vaccinated
80 million people or 25 percent of
people who are eligible are not uh this
is not intended to be a dividing uh
issue it's intended to actually an or a
political issue uh what his objective is
is to deliver on what he thinks uh he
promised the american people just to
save their lives um ultimately uh there
jen why hasn't the president banned the
virus for because there's broad support
for them across the country uh whether
that is making sure we have more roads
rails and bridges that are fixed or
making sure that we
do more to save money to reduce costs
for middle class and working-class
families so yes we do see some loud
vocal opponents of what the president
announced yesterday that's not a
surprise um it's unfortunate it's
disappointing it's sad because
ultimately these steps will save lives
but we remain confident in our ability
to move the agenda forward good thanks
jen why include the option to test out
in this new labor department beautiful
question uh for businesses you mean you
mean instead of just requiring
businesses vaccine ultimately businesses
are going to make those decisions um and
this is a way to implement uh the ocean
osho
regulations that by the way are part of
what has been federal law for more than
50 years that's why we have the capacity
and the ability to do this and we think
it's going to have a huge
impact
many businesses may choose the option of
allowing for
testing as an option many may choose
that they should just uh just make
vaccines the requirement but it leaves
it up to them to make that decision they
do testing who pays for the testing is
it the business or the employee
i
would believe it's probably per business
make that decision but i would
that most would believe the best that's
an issue the president has said
previously he did not want to mandate
the vaccine so can you explain why his
thinking on this has changed sure well
first um i know he said that back in
december or january so eight nine months
ago and i've touched on a couple of the
components that we feel have have
changed a bit
one is that
we didn't anticipate once the vaccine
was readily widely available and free to
the public across the country anyone who
wants a vaccine has been able to get one
for months that there would be such
opposition to it especially given it was
approved under
the former president a republican
president um you know the second uh
piece of this is that we um also uh
anticipated or maybe we didn't
anticipate but we knew that a number of
people were waiting for fda approval
to get the vaccine
that they said that once it's approved
by the fda that's what i'm really
waiting for uh there were more people
who were vaccinated in august than july
but there are still 80 million people
who are not vaccinated
and the third piece is again the
vulnerability of children of
immuno-compromised and other to the
transmission even though our staff is
fully vaccinated i might just start
testing them daily just for kicks been
open too and uh taking steps that we're
going to save more lives protect more
people and that's exactly what
yesterday's announcement is a reflection
of last question is he now considered
mandating vaccinations to fly
domestically please
we are always looking at more we can do
wow and save lives obviously he made a
significant and bold
announcement yesterday so i have
anything to pre predict or do it to fly
we'll continue to look for ways to save
more lives i like that go ahead thank
you jen um so just to clarify is the
thing that was preventing the president
from issuing these mandates earlier the
fda approval is that what the white
house was waiting for before announcing
nothing preventing but i would say
obviously our preference would be that
the 80 million people who are not
vaccinated got the vaccine when it was
available they didn't
so it's our role it's the president's
role as the president of the united
states to continue to take steps to
protect the american people and save
lives that's what it's a reflection the
fall would be if
if these mandates are necessary given
the risk of the delta variant given
hospitalizations and ultimately to save
lives as you were saying why not do this
earlier why not do it a month ago when
hospitalizations were on the rise you
know this has been a concern for a while
this has actually been building on the
staff biden's terrible both for
mandating the vaccines and for not
mandating the vaccine soon enough
additional step yesterday there were a
number of private sector companies many
we encouraged who came out and put in
place mandates and requirements this is
building on the steps we had taken but
again
there are a range of factors that have
happened over the last several months
and it's only natural that we continue
to look for more ways to save lives
given we're at the point where clearly
we're in the most
vaccine resistant population and we've
also seen let me just say we've also
seen it works uh we've seen companies
put in place a vaccine requirements
we've seen the impact of those and the
number of people in at united airlines
at other companies get vaccinated within
the timeline that it's required and you
know that's something that uh made sense
is the administration considering
offering federal funding to states who
mandate this
i don't have anything else to preview or
predict for you in terms of additional
next steps obviously we made a big bold
announcement yesterday so i don't have
anything new to preview for you
go ahead um considering the critical
role of the fda why has president biden
not yet nominated an fda director
he's eager to find the right person to
fill that role i would note that just
like any agency there are hundreds of
people who are career employees the
backbone of the federal government who
are working every day to get the job
done and these agencies certainly
continue to function at a high level
even without a director even if his
preference of course would be to have a
confirmed director in place and on
another topic does the white house want
to see a debt limit increase in the
continuing resolution oh here we go
the white house we continue to believe
that democrats and republicans should do
what they have done 80 times which is to
raise the debt limit and that is what we
are working toward but i'm not going to
get into what vehicle may look like
that's certainly something we'll have
discussions with about with congress and
congressional leaders and uh but we'll
we'll leave that to them
go ahead
drilling down
drilling down on the legal implications
or uh the
the legal underpinnings of this decision
for this osha regulation can you talk
about
what type of legal analysis happened
before the announcement yesterday good
question out of the white house the
white house office of council or was
that done in the labor department and
also it's part of the reason why there's
a testing opt out is that because there
was a thought that that would allow this
rule to be better able to stand up to
legal spread great question so we don't
actually anticipate i mean this is a law
so congress passed a law in 1970 the
occupational safety and health act uh
and the reason the department of labor
and osha is able to take this strong
step to protect americans from covet is
that congress passed that law
yesterday's announcement uh by the
department of labor is proceeding under
that law and the law basically uh
requires the department of labor take
action when it finds grave risk to
workers and certainly a pandemic that
killed more than 600 000 people
qualifies as grave risk to workers and
so if the secretary determines workers
are in grave danger he has an obligation
to issue an emergency temporary standard
that's exactly what he did
with that was there an official analysis
done to or was it just a decision that
the department of labor said clearly
everything we do
we we obviously review legally
everything every bill in every bill we
support every
announced policy announcement we make
but i think that's pretty clear it
doesn't even take a legal degree to
understand that
another topic of the call with uh
president xi
of china how long was that and also did
they discuss a meeting in person at the
g20
um it was about 90 minutes um the call
the president has spent um a lot of time
with president xi in the past as he's
talked about publicly and he drew on
that shared experience in this call so
the call was very familiar
it was candid he didn't avoid areas of
disagreement but the tone was not
lecturing nor was it condescending it
was respectful it was 90 minutes
i don't have anything to preview for you
in terms of future meetings i would note
that um this call was about
keeping the channels of communication
open uh and what we've seen is that the
importance here is about engaging she
directly at the leader level due to the
centralization of power
and the power that's in his hands hence
that was the importance of the call it
covered a range of topics
what thank you jen
after the rule is implemented do you
know how long companies will have to
comply
great question that will be i believe
part of the rule making process um so i
expect we'll have more on that once
that's completed do you have anything to
share about how you landed on employers
with 100 employees or more
why not
the entire world is that person actually
talking
she appears not to be even moving at all
of labor i will say it obviously impacts
um
a huge number of people so we think it
will have an enormous impact on
businesses on companies and communities
in the workforce but um you know it was
determination made by the labor
department can you talk about the
enforcement body how robust that's going
to be since we're talking about a huge
number is that actually who's talking
right now
um
i know jeff zion said they're fine it's
not i knew it i knew it
it's a different asian reporter you
gotta be kidding me guys
again these are all good questions i
knew the voice was ouijas and i'm like
this is a different reporter to be
specific 13 600 uh per violation uh but
this is all a part of what would be
determined in the coming weeks clip it
please
public health experts including the
former surgeon general that is something
huh that is something people were
telling me i was wrong patients that
yeah the
the moves to end masking back in may
were premature do you have a response to
that i'm sorry and also um in light of
that are there any efforts coming up to
talk about masks again because the last
we heard it was you know kind of
confusing but you only need to do it
sometimes if it's high transmissibility
um which is now the case i think
nationwide
so
the president i don't have a response to
the former surgeon general i will say
that factually back in may when we made
that announcement the delta variant was
about one percent of cases
obviously things have changed since that
period of time it's incredibly
transmissible and obviously as we've
noted even as vaccines became widely
available to the country there are still
today 80 million people who are not
vaccinated so our responsibility is to
continue to take steps that will protect
people save lives and that's what we're
focused on the president did talk about
masks yesterday and fines on airplanes
and what would be required in that
regard also masking as it relates to
school certainly protects children and
kids uh from transmissibility and the
spread of the virus and what i would say
is we do agree it's not just about
vaccines it's whoa
oh
okay you know what's happening um
technical elements making noise now
okay
okay it's okay no worries
i didn't know if that was a video game
or an alarm or if we should evacuate
okay
thank you okay great so go ahead to
follow up on the call with president xi
last night exactly two weeks ago when
the intel community came up empty trying
to figure out the origins of coven the
president said came up empty information
about the origins of this pandemic
exists in the people's republic of china
when he talked to the president of china
last night did he press him like he said
he was going to well i i'm not going to
go into list of every
uh topic discussed that was a very
dramatic country to that answer but i'll
start again um i'm not going to go into
every uh list of every topic discussed
they did discuss a range of
transnational issues including including
kovid 19 and understanding its origins
is of course a primary concern for this
administration we continue to support
phase two of the who's investigation in
china and call on china to allow further
studies of covet-19s origins in china i
will also note that
you know one of the topics the
president's also discussed is the
importance of being able to have private
discussions between the two leaders
this is in contrast to some of the other
interactions we've had at lower levels
with the prc
and so yes it was a topic raised but i'm
not going to go into further detail so
we should understand that to mean that
the president did ask him to let
international investigators in to get
this information that he says china has
we've conveyed that many times publicly
pretty weak sauce huh position
on this 90 minute phone call
again peter this is a topic that we have
said conveyed many times at many levels
i'm just not going to have more on the
call to read out for you and then why is
it that you're trying to require anybody
with a job or anybody who goes to school
to get the kobe 19 vaccine but you are
not requiring that of migrants to
continue walking across the southern
border into the country
well look our objective is to get as
many people vaccinated across the
country as humanly possible and so the
president's announcement yesterday was
an effort to empower there's also tens
of millions of people in the first
category and not that many in the second
that's exactly what we did but certainly
we want everybody to get vaccinated and
more people are vaccinated whether they
are migrants or whether they are workers
protects more people in the united
states there's a requirement for people
at a business with more than 100 people
it is not a requirement for migrants of
the southern border why that's correct
go ahead
[Laughter]
lawyers who refuse to implement oh my
god
but what
to
about
with their rights
will federal contractors or
employees be fired and is that the
recommendation
for private sector employees who don't
comply
well again there needs to be rule making
that will take place as it relates to
the osha requirements and that is the
one that repo applies to private sector
companies of individuals 100 people and
over we have our own rules in the
federal government which are applied
through different statutes so yes you're
right there will be count there would be
counseling we are certainly going to
take every step to convey the safety and
efficacy of these vaccines
to federal employees but certainly
vaccination is required for contractors
and employees and the president was
pretty clear about that yesterday
people could get fired correct
and then on another topic um
rapid testing in europe rapid tests are
cheap pretty widely available in the us
it still can be expensive and hard to
find
why is that and why hasn't the
administration been able to address some
of those issues before this latest plan
rolled out
well i would say we just started to
address some of those big issues
yesterday because we recognized as you
said that this was a hindrance for many
people now we did take steps to include
funding for
testing in the american rescue plan that
has been applied in schools and
communities across the country but what
we've seen is an increased interest in
rapid tests and at home tests and we're
being responsive to that as well and
this kind of goes back to the comments
of uh jerome adams i mean testing is
also a component that probably we don't
talk about enough um or
the world doesn't talk about enough
because it is important and it's a way
to make sure people have pr have are
protected we know the demand for rapid
tests has more than doubled in recent
weeks and so we're also being responsive
to that so it's nearly two billion
dollar investment and wrap it at home
test 280 million tested do we know what
the cost
discount is going to be that starts next
week that was announced by biden i still
haven't seen it top retailers are going
to be selling them so we tried to take a
number of steps bold steps from the
federal government and working with the
private sector to make them more rapidly
available go ahead jen what does the
white house say to those businesses some
business groups are expressing this
concern that this
requirement that they either have their
employees be vaccinated or that they be
tested is ultimately a burden on the
businesses so what does the white house
say about that burden because it's
certainly a costly liability some say
well the the vaccines are free and
available to everyone in the country so
that shouldn't be costly or available or
given an opt-out so in other words if
they say they want to do the weekly
tests you couldn't say earlier who would
pay for that test business are saying
how do we get these tests to our
employees what if our employees don't
want to pay for it themselves do we have
to pay for it what does that cost us at
the end of the day give it guys it can't
be 37
because they're already only 10 bucks
each so the cost can't be 37. may not
decide to do that that's up to them to
decide to do so
to make that decision or just swallow
the cost
correct most of these businesses can
absolutely afford it and what we're
talking about here is saving people's
lives and protecting them i'd also say
there are a number of companies that
have already applied this have already
put requirements in place it makes for
safer workplaces it makes people want to
come back to the workplace makes for
healthier and happier employees who know
that they are safe when they go to work
and
that's a cost as well obviously testing
is cheaper for a place like united they
can afford it more easily than a
business that's only 100 people big
that's why i ask i understand but again
vaccines free available everywhere in
the country uh
requiring that is a way is is is not is
free and shouldn't cost businesses any
money
um religious exemptions right now can
you give us a better understanding how
does that how will that work i know how
you said there will be religious
exemptions
well it'll be a whole legal morass
how about four mega churches other
religious organizations in this country
of more than 100 employees what right do
they have under these yet to be created
rules again the rules are being
recreated but we have obviously had
religious exemptions even for federal
employees i'm sure that will be a factor
taken into consideration but
i don't i can't make a prediction of
what the final rules will look like the
attention as i presume that if you're a
religious organization you say hey we
don't want to have to do this in our
organization again this is going to be
for osha to determine as they're doing
the rulemaking in the department of
labor so uh i will not get ahead of that
process let me ask you about 911 if i
can the president who said his remarks
are going to be coming out
what special carve-outs could we give to
the very same mega-churches that have
been causing more problems this entire
pandemic is in advance of tomorrow as
best you can what conversations phone
calls he's had with those who may have
lost loved ones with past presidents
with foreign leaders just as he prepares
for his reflections and then separately
why will he not be delivering remarks of
some kind tomorrow well i would say
first on the second question the
president felt it was important to visit
each of these three sites
to commemorate the lives lost the
sacrifices made on a day that has
impacted millions of people across the
country but certainly many people in
those communities in order to do that
he's attending a ceremony where several
other former presidents and
prominent officials are
going to be hearing the names of the
those lives that were lost around that
period of time isn't it isn't a moment
where there's a lengthy speaking program
and then he's going to be laying wreaths
to commemorate the lives and honor those
whose lives have lost we're releasing
the video today because we want you to
hear from him and he he wants the
american people to hear from him
directly on uh what 9 11 means to him 20
years later and so that's why we're
doing in advance of his trip tomorrow
the first part of that question for the
conversations he's had with has he had
conversations with delawareans with
other americans who lost
loved ones
what what has what have these days
leading up to 9 11 looked like for him
as he's prepared for these records i'm
happy to check if there's been any
conversations that fall into that
category absolutely
good
so we've reported that some members of
the cabinet will be meeting to discuss
trade issues including a new probe on
allegedly illegal subsidies
can you confirm that and how does that
meeting dovetail with the call with xi
last night in which the two leaders
talked about preventing competition from
turning into conflict
wouldn't a new trade probe be an
escalation of
hostilities well first i would say that
certainly uh economic uh topics um were
a part of the discussion last night but
they were not a major part of the
90-minute call that the president had
with
president xi and it wasn't a call that
was intended to uh produce final
outcomes see this is where i think saki
is not so good
where
she was asked
what i would first if i were her right i
would first go at
i can't possibly characterize
or speculate about whether something
that's not been announced
would be an escalation of hostilities
right i mean it's like you you
i think that there's an opportunity for
her to be a little stronger rather than
well what i would say to that is which
sounds almost like she's coming up with
something i can't speculate about
something that hasn't happened why not
the president believes that
democrats and republicans in congress
should do what they've done 80 times in
the past and raised the debt ceiling
shouldn't be a political issue it's
something that
is about the full faith and the faith
and credit of the united states
government something that most of them
most of the republicans voted to do
three times under the last
administration even after two trillion
dollars in tax cuts that certainly added
to the debt did not did not subtract
from the debt uh were passed by these
same members so that continues to be his
call and just one more question on uh
afghans there are thirty 000 afghans at
foreign bases in third countries with
varying immigration status
has the administration advised or
pressured any of those refugees to
accept asylum in countries other than
the us
if they want to relocate here and aren't
disqualified for visa programs will they
be able to
well there is a process that
has been underway for some time we're
very grateful to these countries
who have been served as lily pads as
we've called them to have refugees who
are trying to leave
afghanistan and we couldn't hesitate in
getting these individuals who had fought
by our side and played a pivotal role
over the last 20 years
some of them many of them will come to
the united states some of them will go
to other third countries
that is part of the process i don't
think that's a pressure but that's
always been part of the plan
that we've discussed there will be many
of them who will be eligible for
programs in the united states
some of them may end up in other
countries and that's always been part of
the plan
go ahead thanks jen i've got questions
on the president's announcement
yesterday business owners are already
voicing concerns they aren't able to
find applicants for jobs there are a
record 10.9 million job openings is the
administration at all concerned that
this new vaccine mandate that applies to
businesses with a hundred or more
employees will cause further staffing
shortages and shortages for businesses
now look i think one there are a number
of businesses across the country have
already applied these requirements and
they could be a model some of them i
understand you may be asking about
smaller businesses but it's
for employees of 100 and more um and
certainly uh when the president made the
decision to put in place these policies
and to announce them yesterday he made
it based on uh his number one objective
which is to protect people in this
country and save more lives and he also
announced yesterday additional
assistance for small businesses that was
a part of his plan in short to ensure
they have the assistance they need but
75 of people in this country have been
vaccinated who are eligible i've been
vaccinated 25 percent have not so uh
that's what our target is that's what
our objective is no our goal is not to
place undue burden our goal is to save
lives and that's what we hope this will
do
colleen's earlier questions about rapid
tests which the president mentioned
yesterday he's going to be using the
defense production act uh to add roughly
280 million of these rapid at-home tests
they are talking about rapid tests not
pcrs as far as i understand less than
one kit per person in the country so
what else can be done to ramp up those
tests and to bring down the potentially
prohibitive cost of these tests if
they're going to be used on a regular
basis well one of the steps we took was
to work with big private sector
retailers to make these tests available
and certainly that's has is that it's
planned for the next three months where
we expect there will be a great need but
we will continue to look as there are
needs uh to make sure people in the
country have the resources they need
this is not the end but this is
certainly a significant announcement
yesterday
is there a goal for how many at-home
rapid tests should be available beyond
the 200 again i think announcing the two
the numbers we had the thing is most
people have no interest in buying rapid
tests at home like if you've not been
wearing a mask and you're not vaccinated
you're not interested in testing people
i mentioned i went to a birthday a
couple weeks ago with 12 people
everybody was tested on the way and
everybody was also vaccinated everybody
also has been doing everything the i
don't think there's going to be the
demand that they're implying where if
you have 280 million every person will
be able to get one china is willing to
play an active role at the upcoming cup
summit about climax
um i'm not going to speak for what their
intentions are at the cops summit of
course i would note that of course
climate around
as well as a number of topics were
discussed and the cop summit is uh the
next big moment for the international
community on that front uh and certainly
uh human rights um were part of the
discussion uh
and the president did raise them as he
always does in these engagements go
ahead
a question about wildfires
presidents traveling to idaho and
california to survey wildfire damage
when he had his meeting with the western
governors earlier this year governor
newsom and others voiced frustration
with the u.s forest service
accused them of having a wait-and-see
culture the president announcing any
policy changes any new developments on
strategy to wildfires when he's out
there you'll have to wait and see
uh and a a question on
uh just the backlash from
a state attorney's general can you exp
can you expand on why
why the 1970 law does cover specifically
these requirements for businesses sure
let me try it again um
so the 1970 law
which
has now been in place to do the math for
all of you for 51 years
um
it's a law that required let me give you
the exact statement of it here um
right
um
it requires the department of labor to
take action when it finds grave risk to
workers and certainly a pandemic that
has killed more than 600 000 people uh
where 25 of eligible people who are have
not been vaccinated poses a grave risk
and so this uh what department of labor
was proceeding under that duly enacted
law it actually um
determines uh the the is require has an
obligation i should say to issue an
emergency temporary standard when it
meets that bar uh so that is the um
background on that or the information on
that go ahead
will the administration will the
administration consider revisiting
federal emergency unemployment benefits
as delta continues to impact the job
market
well we've talked about this a little
bit in here in the past and just to note
about half of the states
that had been so the back story is
yesterday the enhanced unemployment and
and three other programs all ended but
26 states had already ended them ahead
of time yesterday was the federal end
quite a range so point is they have
different needs and what we've been
doing has been working with leaders in
these states governors other leaders to
figure out how
funding from the american rescue plan
state and local funding and other
funding can be used to apply for
specific categories of benefits should
they feel those benefits are needed but
we haven't seen actually the issue in
the economy which still has issues that
we're still recovering from
to be an employment issue there are
other issues that we're working to
states in the addre of the states that
did stop
the aid early there wasn't any sign that
it actually impacted there was
employment rates so
i mean
is there no additional steps that the
white house wants to take do they want
to see congress take action on that or
i mean how else do you expect to maybe
help governors who or push governors who
decide that they don't want to
use that aid
that's been provided federally
for unemployment that is aid that's
available and as governors decide uh as
we work with governors to determine how
to help people in the states who still
need help
which is imperative and one of the
reasons why the american rescue plan was
designed in the way it was was so that
the child tax credit and other programs
are going out in the months ahead and
into next year so the point is that
there is state and local funding that
can be used we're working with these
states to implement that funding if your
unemployment rate is three percent you
have different needs and if your
unemployment rate is seven or eight
percent so that's the point i was making
as it relates to how we apply these
programs
that's good uh the administration
obviously believes that more
requirements are necessary to get more
people vaccinated but of the 80 million
people who are not yet gotten their
first shot
what amount does the administration
assess are still persuadable and what
amount do you think actually need the
the force of government to make them do
it
well that's a hard that's a hard
question to assess from here
i will say clearly we felt that putting
in place additional steps and
requirements was essential to get more
of the 80 million people vaccinated i
can't tell you how many of you guys i
can't tell you how many people are
getting banned on twitch and youtube
people that have been following for 10
or 15 minutes and just showing up and
immediately just filling our our live
chat with just bottom feeding garbage
persuade at this point well at this
point it's really hard to give a number
on that right and i don't want to
irresponsibly guess at that from here
but
at this point the vaccines have been
widely available across the country for
months in communities across the country
for months we have mobile clinics we
have we've done it in many different
ways and communities
so uh we're assessing that
some of these requirements are the next
lever needed to get more people
vaccinated and ultimately protect more
people in the country
you said earlier the president's not
making remarks tomorrow he's releasing a
video ahead of time correct
does not what
a speech in any of the three locations
right exactly
thank you a couple of foreign policy
questions the first one the taliban and
the qataris are insisting that flights
out of afghanistan are no longer
evacuations but kind of business as
usual for travelers with documentation
i've noticed that emily horn's statement
on the fly side came out today as well
as yesterday did also not use the word
evacuation so can you confirm whether
the administration is still considering
and treating these flights out of
afghanistan as evacuations
we're considering them people departing
who want to depart of
afghanistan i'm not sure that the word
matters
the second one is on the israeli prime
minister who is calling on the
international community to act quickly
and immediately against iran following
an iea report that uh tehran has
dramatically increased production of
uranium highly enriched uranium in
recent months do you have a comment on
that i will get you a comment from our
national security team
the administration seriously considering
a request from taiwan to change the name
of its mission in the washington in
washington from taipei economic and
cultural representative office to taiwan
representative office i have i i would
have to check with our team on this
issue go ahead two questions on one on
afghanistan one on vaccinations if i
could on on afghanistan i'm curious if
there have been any offers of
resignation from anyone in the chain of
command or
any anyone involved in the decisions
with the she'll never answer that no
if the answer was yes
yes if there were offers that biden said
you don't need to resign she would never
she would never answer that uh the
president's second shot was in january
uh if you follow that logic uh eight
months afterwards you're supposed to get
the booster that would have been last
month for the president has the
president gotten the booster is he going
to get the booster over there he's not
gotten it yet uh we'll wait till it's
widely available which we expect to be
soon go ahead
i'm hearing that the bureau of prisons
issued a memo today um telling
approximately about a thousand drug
offenders how to apply for clemency have
you do you have anything on that
i would certainly point you to the
department of justice i would say that
the president has been clear about his
openness to using clemency powers but uh
i don't i wouldn't say that's an
assessment of decisions made and
certainly targeting those toward
non-violent drug offenders but i'd point
to the department of justice for any
further details a follow-up um on the
mandates
with companies like delta now
having a 200
premium that they're going 200 that
they're going to add to the insurance
premiums how does the president feel
about companies trying to persuade
people to get vaccines by doing that
well
there are a range of ways we've
recommended companies try to incentivize
people uh get vaccinated including
mandating them including putting in
place requirements and many have taken
creative steps so there's a range of
ways to look at that's not one we've
advocated for but obviously different
companies will make different choices
good
thank you jen not to try to share any
any vaccine skeptics in africa people
are looking for vaccine but they can't
find them in the u.s there is an
abundance of vaccine but up to 80
million people have refused to receive
them and 1500 people are dying every day
would you say that too much privilege is
sending so many americans to their early
grades
i'm not sure what your question is
is privilege we're sending many people
to the early grave
well i would say first that the united
states uh wants to be
an arsenal vaccine distribution to the
goal she misunderstood the question she
misunderstood the question more than
every other country in the world
combined she seems to be answering what
she thinks the question was which is
shouldn't you send the vaccines to other
countries he was saying is privileged
killing people the steps that we
announced yesterday we need to do both
so i was asking is too much privilege
killing people in the u.s like there's
so much vaccine available here
where people are refusing to take them
while in africa people don't even have
access to vaccine and they want to have
them are we all right let's say
to the extent that we are ready to die
instead of taking the vaccine
well i i think that's a hard question i
don't know that i have a comment on that
from the u.s government i would i would
say that
our objective here is to convey to
people not in a political way whenever
we can avoid it that um i like that guy
i i've not noticed that guy in the press
briefing room before i like him one and
they'll save your neighbors your friends
your grandparents and that's our
objective okay i think i gotta keep
going here oh no i gotta keep going go
ahead thanks john um could you confirm
that there's going to be an in-person
cost summit in washington dc on
september 24th and in person i'm sorry
oh uh sorry i couldn't at the maths are
hard sometimes and they're important um
i will have more details i don't have
anything to announce at this point nice
enough taiwan during the phone call with
president
i'm not uh i'd have to check uh but i
don't have anything on that in the
readout go ahead mike uh jen obviously
congress has a lot on its plate next
week but we're also going to see the
beginning of oversight hearings
secretary of state tony blinken will be
the first up
as part of the different committees
looking into the afghanistan decision
fallout what role is the white house
playing in terms of
preparations for these hearings and
might we expect any white house
officials to be part of public hearings
on capitol hill well uh we've been uh
cooperating working with congress
briefing them regularly throughout the
course of the last several weeks and
that will continue and we'll certainly
continue to provide officials as
appropriate uh moving forward um as it
relates to preparations i'd certainly
point to the state department we're
still a week away but they're uh a
capitol police is
reinstalling some of the perimeter
fencing around the capitol yes so these
justice for
j6 protests demonstrations that are
expected um how closely is the white
house monitoring these not just in
washington but across the country and
have any white house officials express
interest or concern about maybe
reinstalling some of the fencing we saw
around the white house grounds in
january well we're always going to
assess what security measures need to be
put in place but we typically don't
preview them and i'm not going to put do
that from here obviously the capital and
leadership in congress takes their own
steps and we certainly trust them to
make decisions about how to protect the
members of their
caucuses
shelley
thanks uh just two quick ones for you
does the administration consider this
latest vaccine mandate for private
sector companies to be a workaround for
the federal government to require
vaccines
no meaning to require them for the
american people
well this is a a tool a step that again
there's legal authority for based on a
50 year old law and one that we took
action on uh because the president
wanted to use every lever at his
disposal to
protect more people and save more lives
but no it's not we don't have the
ability to tell every american you have
to be vaccinated there's a means of
encouraging it of mandating it uh
through certain uh
through certain pathways and that's
exactly what we've done all right thanks
everyone
wow an abrupt end to a two-hour late
press briefing
uh okay well
a lot of people banned today we're just
dropping ban hammers it's just like
we're just having to
play whack-a-mole with people it's crazy
we're just just everywhere everywhere
banning banning um really appreciate
everybody who joined me today
and there will be more streams there
will be more of everything all right
we'll see everybody very soon